welcome everybody thank you for being
here for this wonderful occasion to hear
and honor Bill T Jones today my name is
in there Paul Gray well and professor in
women's gender and sexuality studies and
this year I'm part of the LGBT Committee
and before I turn it over to Professor
Amy Cox to introduce our honoree I want
to say a few words of thanks to all
those who made this award and made this
event possible
so I don't know if you know but James
Bruckner after whom this award is named
was an AIDS activist and urban planner
journalist and a photographer he was a
man of wit and compassion outside
knowledge and curiosity and he's valued
academic inquiry direct action and
artistic expression he spent 12 years as
a policy analyst in the city of New York
earned an MA in journalism from NYU and
wrote for various publications on gay
and AIDS related topics he became a
member of act-up which you'll know about
the treatment action group and other
organizations after the death of his
twin brother Erik of AIDS in in 1980s 87
he worked on many prevention and
treatment issues with a my age and with
pharma corporations and federal agencies
and in his final years he devoted much
of his truck time to traveling the back
roads of rural America with a camera jim
died of aids-related illness on
September 18th 1998 at the age at the
young age of 37 through his will he
established the Brandner prize at Yale
as a perpetual annual prize for
scholarship and activism on gay and
lesbian history and contemporary
experience the Brandon prize has thus
far honor the long lists of activists
artists and scholars who have done
critical work in this area and we offer
we give our thanks to the donors of the
prize Steve Karlin Michael corny a
and Ben Posner for making this happen
today this event would not have been
possible without the work of Maureen
Gardner back there whose are in our
office in adult in women gender and
sexuality studies who takes care of all
the logistics and arrangements to Ashley
lead us ravines who's also in the back
there who makes all the work possible to
the LGBTQ committee today
Jill Richards Jill where are you
Greta Lafleur Greta and Avron subject
who worked through the year to advance
lgbts studies at Yale University I want
to also recognize the help and support
of Professor Emily Coates in the dance
department who's there
whose research and instruction at Yale
are invaluable to advanced dance in many
interdisciplinary and broadening ways
here I want to finally also thank the
Whitney Humanities Center and last but
not least yo gala for their support as
well but before I introduce professor
Cox I want to recognize the enthusiasm
and presence of the community dance
group from the neighborhood music school
who are sitting in front reach out for
them and their teacher Canon I mean who
has who's come here with some very
excited and enthusiastic students future
dancers and current and future dancers
let me then turn to introduce professor
Amy Cox she is just the perfect person
to be talking introducing our honoree
today professor Cox is a dancer and an
anthropologist whose presence at Yale
has brought a wonderful synergy across
Black Studies performance studies dance
Studies an ethnography she's jointly
appointed as an associate professor in
the department's of African American and
anthropology here her first monograph
shapeshifters black girls in the
choreography of citizenship which came
out in 2015
won a 2016 Victor Turner Book Prize in
ethnographic writing
very prestigious price and honorable
mention in the 2016 Gloria Anzaldua book
price given by the National Women's
Studies Association this book examines
choreography as an aesthetic practice
embodied and used by young black women
in Detroit's fresh start shelter and she
does she can do this pull together this
work because she's also a former
professional dancer who danced with
Alvin Ailey and the Dance Theatre of
Harlem her next ethnographic project
living class slow death explores the
creative protest strategies individuals
and communities in act two in to reclaim
black life in the urban United States
[Applause]
hi welcome good afternoon you can say
thank you I need some colony spots thank
you thank you for that we are so
fortunate to be able to gather in this
space today to honor bill T Jones
choreographer director writer dancer
spectacular change agent and now the
recipient of the 2018-19 James R Britain
er eighty-three Memorial Prize and LGBT
studies when we were planning for this
day last year I knew I would be on
sabbatical but I also knew no matter
where I was in the world whether that
was a deep Delta of Mississippi where I
actually was and I would come back to be
a part of this day because so often in
the Academy we are called to these
podiums under the presumption that we
will pontificate and critique
demonstrate our facility with theory
essentially prove our intellect but I
thought you'd be here so I turn back and
look at you but let me tell you it's
exhilarating to approach the mic to
simply unapologetically fawn over
someone's undeniable greatness and that
is bill teeger
[Applause]
bill T Jones I'm honored to celebrate
all that you have given us and the
countless ways you continue to challenge
us to live more courageously or what
some might call to simply be better you
demand this through the over 100 works
you have created for your own company
the bill T Jones Arnie Zane Dance
Company as well as other dance
collectives and theatre productions you
demand this through the power and beauty
of your lyrical prose you demand this
through the searing truth-telling
embedded in every and your every spoken
word and we need you and your work now
perhaps more than ever and 2002 you said
and I quote I dare you in this the base
culture to put yourself out there on the
line that is my politics right now it is
a politics of transformation it is hard
to believe that was 17 years ago we are
here still still here every day confront
it with the same old ways of destroying
and slowly killing one another but
dressed up in what we might name now as
Neil cruelties the bodies you've set in
motion however even when dancing solos
are statements on a Rihanna
relationality that is a threat to this
slow death could our connection to other
bodies to other spaces to other souls to
other ways of being that we might only
for now be able to access on the fuzzy
edges of our memory or the speculative
plain of imagination lead us to
something that may approach
transformation there is no doubt that
you're engaged in that engagement with
your work catalyzes change the to
numerous to name awards and accolades
you have earned our partial testimony to
this including your 1994 MacArthur award
the 2006 Lucille Lortel award the
induction into the Ameritech American
Academy of Arts and Sciences in 2009 in
2009 the 2010
Center honors your two Tony Awards for
Spring Awakening in 2007 and Fela in
2010 but I don't want to spend this time
naming the long list of awards that we
can all easily read in our programs or
that I'm sure if we didn't already know
we googled before our arrival here today
I am NOT of course implying that these
awards are not important they are
on the contrary significant responses to
a rich body of fiercely innovative work
but they can only point to your impact
on our lives
I sometimes think of awards as the Amen
choir that responds after we have
already shouted fallen out and danced
with the spirits they come a little late
so I was talking about Bill T Jones in
this particular award a few days ago
with a good friend of mine Bernard
Gilmore who was a dancer with the Alvin
Ailey American Dance Theatre in 2013 the
Ailey company performed d-man in the
waters the work that our Yale student
dancers are currently rehearsing
d-man in the waters premiered at the
Joyce Theater in New York City in 1989
during the height of the AIDS epidemic
and remains a demanding work to both
witness and dance every new audience
member every new dancer every new
generation is called by this exceptional
piece to contend with the tensions
between mortality and life the
inevitability of loss and the inevitable
will to survive despite and sometimes
because of those things and structures
and people and ideas that would end us
Bernard had this to say about working
with Bill T Jones and I'm quoting him
bill is the ultimate artist he demand
your full commitment and once your very
best you can't go through the motions or
pretend with Bill he sniffs out what is
false and is only interested in your
willingness to bring all of who you are
so you can see all of who you could be
and you had to do this every time at
every rehearsal but unlike some other
choreographers he mainly asked this
through his present
he walks into the room and you could
sense that you can't show up how you
used to you had to dig deeper and find
your better self I often failed but I'm
still trying it was Jones as presents
this combination of palpable spiritual
strength and kinetic magnetism that I
experienced for the first time close up
in the early 2000s bill and his company
were performing in Ann Arbor and holding
master classes at the University of
Michigan where I was a graduate student
in anthropology at the time although I
had danced with the - fear of Harlem and
Ailey - I hadn't danced professionally
or even had a technical dance class in
over three years I had convinced myself
that I had to convince myself that I was
no longer a dancer if I was to be taken
seriously in the context of a doctoral
program I was a fool I know but more
than that I was terrified of being my
full self in the ways that Bernard
points to in his reflection on his time
rehearsing d-man in the waters I had
taken huge master classes led by Jones
and his company in New York City in the
mid to late 90s but was the face in the
crowd
but as soon as he walked into the studio
on that day in Ann Arbor I felt a
vibrational pool that drew me to him and
before I could stop myself I heard
myself say mr. Jones I know you don't
remember me I've taken your classes with
you before years ago I'm sure you don't
remember I don't mean to presume I just
want to tell you that I haven't danced
in a while and and he interrupted me I
do remember you are you ready to dance
no I meant no that's what I wanted to
say I'm out of shape my body my hip no
Jones said and then lay to fingers
lightly at the space around my heart are
you ready to dance in that moment that
clearly still resonates as if it
happened this morning I knew what he
meant I knew what he was asking because
Jones is sincere question is one that
reverberates through all of his
choreography writing and the dialogical
spaces he creates at new
you're Clive arts are you ready are we
ready meaning are we ready to move
beyond the expectations of technique
disciplines and John rossette shrink our
capacities are we ready to approach
movement in the body so that we can
experience a transformation that moves
with and beyond it
are we ready to be here now
informed by the past but not bound by it
and attuned to a future that resists the
allure of fantasy and the easy danger of
hope but instead is built on the
difficult work of self reflexive and
collective serving concrete action are
we ready
I can guess that we are at least ready
to now hear from the brilliant bill T
Jones today as he offers his lecture
insanity sense thinking and making now
won't you please join me in welcoming
bill T Joe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you
oh and the answers in the front row yes
so Emily I'd known this was going to be
happening we should have had the company
because you're gonna hear me jaw on
after that introduction everything she's
talking about yes I speak a lot and I do
have a southern baptists heart we're
trying to heritage for my mother
but the truth is in the movement and its
you see in front of you is an aged
bought body I just found out today at 67
I'm officially considered old now all
right but we won't be concerned thank
you very much everyone I'd like to first
of all thank all those persons who made
it possible for me to receive this prize
and to Jim himself I'd like to thank the
program for lesbian gay bisexual and
transgender studies here at Yale the
program for women's gender and sexuality
studies at Yale the Whitney Humanities
Center and Yale gala and professor ray
all and of course it's so beautiful Amy
which is said it's going to be
discursive it will be heavily anecdotal
I know I came to give it a lecture but
this is how we do it every performance
every speech is an improvisation and I'm
confused about that because I have once
being it's got Egon I was invited to
come up and do studio visits y'all know
Skowhegan right important artist
residency I was colony and I am that
night I was trying to get Rio and do
some of the things that
any drug congratulating me for and I was
saying to people what would you live for
how do you speak your truth and somebody
say yeah you know you're a performer
where we are thinkers artists we work
with a medium you're a performer that's
why it's easy for you to say that so I
understand so I am going to speak today
and I'm going to try to speak in a way
that is performative but it's really
about a conversation and I do hope that
we can speak together later you look
like you're the tution all right they've
seen work
good good good because they're gonna
hear a lot of the stuff behind the work
and I just want you to be sure that you
understand that we what we do is a noble
thing a noble and brave thing because we
use these most elemental possessions
that we have that connect us as human
beings our bodies but today it's about
the the mind everybody here read Moby
Dick is anyone who has not read Moby
Dick it's an honest group well I am I
want to start this way because my speech
my lecture my performative event is
about the experience of each work being
the desire to solve and ask questions
and to solve those questions like many
people who were educated in the 1950s
actually at that time it felt like hell
but actually I realized it was a very
good period small school in upstate New
York potato growing fruit growing
community full of Germans and Italians
and the black folks were there who were
there like the Joneses the williams's
just a handful of us we were the
workforce I'm number 10 of a family of
12 my mother and father made their
living picking potatoes I have picked
the taters I have tied grapes I know
something about
that but we were not supposed to stay
there they this is the American story as
understood by Gus Jones who in 1955
decided to become a black Yankee big
deal I'm born in Bunnell Florida but did
my dad mean by black Yankee he had 12
kids and they removed the older kids
removed sometimes six school systems a
year imagine making new friends six
times a year and you're supposed to be
learning you're reading riting and
rithmetic
are you doing sir it's a great honor to
see that handsome face yes so my dad
wanted to go up north so that his kids
could have the benefits of the white
kids these school books that they had in
the South my older brothers and sisters
said that the teachers had a way of
teaching that the South won the Civil
War they didn't really talk about
slavery the books were terrible they
were scribbled on horrible things were
written in them because they came from
across town at the white schools and
they ended up with the black schools
okay all forgiven we're in a new time
now Hank so let's not spend too much
time
my heart's heavy still and sometimes
with age it gets heavier and I'm the
generation that you little ones close
your ears dropped acid it but at
Woodstock turn on tune in drop out right
freedom freedom rights Moby Dick this
book I read it several times well maybe
one and a half terms but only as an
adult and particularly in the last ten
years I read it again
and there was a character called pip in
it hip VIP why didn't I hear or read him
when I was in high school
was it Ferguson was it Eric garner was
it Trayvon Martin why did that great
novel suddenly become for me about this
11 year old black boy who comes from
Connecticut no he is not up from a slave
situation he is on the Pequod and he is
like a kind of a ship's janitor or what
have you and he ends up one day
literally doing the manly work which is
being in the small slave ships where the
harpooneers are he shouldn't have been
there
he's frightened he could barely swim
that the whale it was underneath above
the boat this is not Moby Dick this is
just nip whale and it bumps the boat he
jumps out scared he jumps out he's in
the water and tangled and mr. Stubb the
first mate says stay in the boat pip
okay they have to decide if they're
going to like release him and lose the
whale and they release him but you know
next time we're gonna leave you now did
they really mean it sure enough he ends
up back in another boat in a few weeks
same thing happens boom then he jumps
out he's petrified and this time just as
they're about to make that fatal
decision because after all as mr. pip
it's said mr. Stubb it said before you
know we can get a lot more for the whale
do we can for you pip they were still
selling black folks at that time so it
was serious but anyways he before they
can decide they spot a school of whales
this is a business they're out there to
make money so there's this little guy in
the water there they all leave now as
Melville says brilliantly they didn't
mean to leave him but the fact is they
had business to attend to and there's
this thing described where in the
ships bobbing in the water after a
minute there a mile and then there four
miles away and then they're gone and he
is alone bobbing in the Pacific Ocean
you know what clothes looks like you
know that's that the spice you know then
he said that his he his little black
head was bobbing up in the Pacific of up
and down like clove and the loneliness
was unbearable
by the merest chance the ship itself at
last rescued him but from that hour the
little Negro went about the deck an
idiot such at least they said he was the
sea had jeeringly kept his finite body
up but drowned the infinite of his soul
not drowned entirely though rather
carried down alive to wondrous deaths
where strange shapes of the unwarped
primal world glided to and fro before
his passive eyes and the miser man
wisdom revealed his hoarded heaps and
among the joyous heartless ever juvenile
eternities pip saw the multitudinous God
omnipresent coral insects that out of
the firmament of waters heaved the
colossal orbs he saw God's foot upon the
treadle of the loom and spoke it and
therefore his shipmates called him mad
soul
man's insanity is heavens since man's
insanity is heaven since now a lot of us
artists play crazy it's a kind of
attractive means you're not responsible
your childlike and your that precious
thing spontaneous and I've been thinking
about this lecture today I don't want my
doctor to be insane I don't want the
person who educates my children to be
insane I don't want my politicians to be
insane mm-hmm but then why do I value
that quality and let me see if I can get
my technology to help me out here and
they went to merriam-webster dictionary
definition of sane for seeding from a
sound mind
rational mentally sound especially able
to anticipate and appraise the effect of
one's actions healthy and body insane
exhibiting a severely disordered state
of mind affected with mental illness
the law says affected with insanity
criminally insane unable to think in a
clear or sensible way crazy used by
typically of or intended for mentally
ill people such as we say in an insane
asylum so as I was saying pip became a
kind of a seer on the boat he could tell
the truth the weakest person on the boat
is like a homeless person he no longer
does his duties but what are you going
to do he's not in the middle of Pacific
Ocean the captain meets him one day and
is struck by him this crazy captain the
most powerful man on the boat the uber
white man on the boat meets the
eleven-year-old black boy who is like an
idiot and he is so moved that he says
you from now on will live with me and he
moves the boy into his cabin this is not
gay it was not homoerotic but there was
something about the power dynamic that
this child spoke to the captain about
insanity and its opposite so what's this
got to do with Bill T Jones when I just
finished my trilogy three works we just
presented it the other night in Boston
three works that are built around oral
histories or two oral histories the
third quasi oral history the first is
about my companion my husband be on a
Mullins mother Jewish woman
on World War 2 who at age 19 is running
to get medicine from her mother who is
dying of cancer as the Nazis are coming
into antwerp she and her sisters escape
to the south of france the father joins
and later the mother has died dora
discovers at that time there's two types
of people those who need help those who
get help and she decides she's going to
be one of those and gives help amazing
woman I love her very much
she's now in a facility in Paris but at
that time I did this oral history with
her for my companion and his brother
because she's telling stories that they
need to have as their patrimony I need
to hear the second one is my nephew
Lance Theodore braze he is very handsome
he was a beautiful boy born in 1970 his
mother Johari Briggs is well this for
the short period now we always fought as
kids because she's only one year older
because I'm at my birthday's February
15th hers is in March so in a few weeks
she'll be a year and a half older than I
am and that was a big deal when we were
kids but I've known Lance since he was a
little boy and Lance was the first gay
child that I knew of in the family bill
was out bill was a freak right bill was
with a white boy this is what you tell
the people talked about who and what I
was but then my sister gives birth to a
very sensitive lively I think
hyperactive kid who loves me his Uncle
Bill he said they had two models you
Uncle Bill and Michael Jackson oh but
everyone loved Michael Jackson right is
it all right to love Michael Jackson now
mm-hmm hashtag out for Michael so I
wanted to make a work
my family Dora is my family but Dora is
a heroic figure Lance is Missy business
here is a child at risk a black child a
black male child great growing up a
black gay male child growing up in San
Francisco in the 1970s rape pet arrest
prostitute by the time he was 14 but
he'd been doing ballet and all he all
uncle billed knew about him was that he
was going to be another dancer in the
family did I really know what it meant
to be 11 12 13 years old in San
Francisco in the early 1970s I didn't
did I want to know no I was too busy
enjoying the fantasy of him having a
middle-class life as a working artist
say it again middle-class life as a
working artist no this was not about
pushing against anything this is the
wanting to be included being able to pay
bills being able to eat what I want
being able to drive the car I want but I
found this out only when he ended up in
jail he now he's paraplegic he's in a
wheelchair I mean he as he said this
vehicle that is my body I ran it until
the wheels came off I wish it was
different I wish it was different but
you'll make up for lunch
yeah now that's a rhetorical one they
don't quite this is this is part of the
performative you know let me do let me
do it for the time being you'll get hurt
you'll get your time and that was then
there was a third one which was based on
a book by WG Sebald
the book is about Ambrose a delight did
the writer actually have an uncle who
was born in the 1890s came to New York
in 1911 a buttoned-up impeccable
manservant who was hired German hired by
one of the wealthiest Jewish banking
families to watch over their son Cosmo
Salomon Cosmo who was prone to
eccentricity Cosmo who ultimately ends
up having a nervous breakdown and dying
in an insane asylum but in the meantime
Ambrose and Cosmo had this relationship
now the right he never says what the
relationship is but there were older
relatives the older Germans who were
quote outclassed by this buttoned-up
impeccable man they were outclassed by
him but he was of the other persuasion
quote other persuasion and the two of
them had this relationship and they
travel in Europe they're in the Holy
Land and so on and that piece is the
third of the trilogy the other night I
was performing in we were performing in
at the ICA in Boston and it was a
wonderful performance the audience
appreciated it very much and then a
woman raised her hand and she had been
watching the door of peace I do a lot of
partnering I know if we know I made my
reputation with Arnie Zane by foot for
Jewish Italian man I'm a six foot one
african-american we were doing this kind
of newfangled partnering a little person
could lift a bigger person
we were rolling in the the ground
together and doing all these outrageous
things together and it was all about
form and reinventing the language of
partnering this language is still at
work in a work like dora and lance and
ambrose but she raised her hand and she
said you know you say your postmodern
but postmodern is about questioning
gender roles now where she got that from
i don't know and she said and I watched
and I timed there was all these duets
and there was only one short moment
where two people two men danced together
and I said also you're saying I'm a
self-hating homosexual no no no no
that's glib but she says that's glib and
maybe I was but what are you saying she
was counting the duets and who was
dancing I teach gender studies she said
and I'm very disappointed oh well well I
said you got to come into the other
pieces you have to see Lance Lance is
you can't get a more gay themed work and
the partnering is gender-blind
Ambrose is about two men who are having
a relationship so here we are
academia and what are the rules and who
determines what is correct and what is
not do you is that what you're being
trained to do and how do you feel about
that okay deep Lucy I made that
connection with pip because I realized
that as much as I have been rewarded
from my work and I've been alone now we
got lovely academics like yourself who
were former dancers there was a gap
between what we were doing downtown and
what mr. Ailey or Arthur Mitchell was
doing they tolerated me but it wasn't
real dancing the avant-garde had
no class no race no gender or so they
said and then they got woke or they're
trying to get woke you know the
guerrilla girls on this was a women's
collective that began to do actions in
the 70s why there were not more
galleries representing female artists
why museums not have more female artists
they were talking back to the power so
they were saying to the avant-garde that
saw itself as classless raceless
genderless you are not and there was
this thing called identity politics and
it became a rallying cry around the time
that Arnie Zane was dying from
complications of AIDS in our bedroom in
my arms with his mother Jewish woman and
his father converted to Judaism my
entire dance company my three sing
Sisters singing Negro spirituals and
Barbra Streisand as he loved Barbra
Streisand this is a time when suddenly
who you were became very important
I remember mr. Ailey died in 1989 and
yes the other day as a matter of fact
yesterday I was being interviewed by mr.
Ailey about mr. alien a document here it
goes me about him and then one of the
questions was you know well hope you can
you take this respectfully mr. Jones but
mr. Ailey was discreet about his his
status discreet and he never spoke about
having AIDS what do you think about now
we're trying to do this and should we
respect that enclosure here's again I
said hell no no don't respect it if
Alban was alive now I think he'd want to
get it right who are we protecting him
from protecting his reputation from
ah to be loved about your community
particularly if their community is
deeply homophobic then it becomes a risk
if you go down with a guilty disease and
that's what AIDS was it was a guilty
disease this happened to people who are
not living right so um Arnie Zane died
in March of 88 alvin ailey died I
believe and 89 we were in Washington
performing at the Kennedy Center when I
got the news the company was about to go
to the theater I think and I heard that
Alvin had died and I was being asked to
come to the National Endowment someone's
buildings in Washington there and
testified before a blue-ribbon panel
about what I think it was about hiv/aids
or something like that but on the way
there I had to walk through
demonstrations now you've heard about
mr. Bruner and his involvement with act
up while the streets were full of people
laying down and the police were all
wearing yellow gloves you know they
never tell you about that there was a
time when if someone had HIV it was
rumoured if you touch them you could get
it so the police are out there rescuing
arresting people who and I'm walking
through this to go to talk to
politicians and art leaders about it and
that was the first day that the day
without art
December 1st was said it was launched
and all arts organizations were asked to
be black that day dark so that the
public would know what was happening to
the artists in their midst my company
was doing d-mat in the waters and it was
hot everyone knew what had happened
Artie had died they knew that we were a
company that had it and yet yours truly
was
out there right Arthur a deal is one of
the most brilliant dancers of his
generation if you're interested in you
should look him up at Leela's avi le s
he runs a theater now in the Bronx but
he was a premier dancer in my group we
didn't have soloists but he was compared
often to Nijinsky because of the beauty
of his body he was a diver berto Rican
man really bought a beautiful body and
very very tough because I brought the
company together I said okay what are we
gonna do they're saying that nobody
should be performing today and we have
our chance to perform at the Kennedy
Center tonight so everyone well I don't
know you know this is so important and
he said I refuse to perform I refuse to
perform so if you have your lead we're
very important dancer who refuses to
perform everybody can't perform so what
did we do we told them that we would not
perform we would be in the theater and
when the audience came tickets in hand
we would say that you know to show
solidarity we would not perform until
12:01 a.m. in the middle of the night so
please come back and we'll perform for
you people were very angry you know how
are you punishing us we're here to see
the work the art the art why are you
punishing us is this politics or is this
art ah is this politics or is this art
so we performed at 12:01 and something
changed I think I understood something
for the first time about that membrane
separates esthetic action from political
action I'm so glad Arthur did that mr.
Reilly
as I was on camera yesterday hopefully
it wasn't too performative I asked his
permission to be talking about him in
the way that we are now allowed to talk
about him we can talk about his problems
with loneliness we can talk about the
fact that here he was the greatest one
of the greatest choreographers America
has ever produced there's no one around
the world like him not in France not in
London it came from this culture kudos
to this troubled culture in this land of
apartheid but he was lonely I remember
visiting him when his company was in LA
we were performing and a smaller theater
and they were no they were a company and
he invited me over because he was asking
me to do a work for the company and I
walked with the day off and all these
beautiful black bodies are in the pool
and so on and everyone's carrying on and
mr. Haley he's up there and I go up to
his room and it's the little dog and
he's sitting in there alone alone who
was taking care of him who was something
about the way it's set up we want your
genius but we're not responsible for you
and how do you do it if you're a person
male female transgender but in
particular gay men what is there about
that see that pip was in that the art
world actually does to you you're out
there alone
and bobbing and oftentimes your body is
held up but your mind goes down and it
cracks so about Jerome Robbins with his
problems from drinking but about how
many artists do we know with drugs and
so on obsessive behavior sexual
addiction and your mind cracks and if
it's if we the world is lucky you still
turn out masterpieces a lot of us just
become
trash garbage and then next next because
that's what it's about isn't it I say
this sometimes and people are maybe of
being dramatic but you know there's
something about our and the way we're
taught to respect genius I say you know
quite frankly they don't care if you eat
children for breakfast as long as you
turn in a masterpiece we can forget your
life that's why I asked about Michael is
it all right to love Michael again
remember what it was like Jacko was he a
pederast all of that one of those
brilliant performers of all time do you
really care
I'll tell you something I don't care I
don't care I want the work I walk the
genius now the deals that I have made
the woman the other night looking at
this beautiful display and she is now
saying you're not correct so there is
now voices coming from both directions
we used to say right wing right wing
right wing now it's the left wing as
well telling you you better do this this
and this artists don't give a damn you
can punish me don't come see it this is
the rules don't let them tell you
anything else do the work make something
meaningful deep connecting the rest of
it is chitter chatter easy to say hard
to do the water bought bears your body
up but your mind gets taken down and
cracked because we need community we
need to be loved as people
but at the same token you are this other
thing snippets
deep blue sea people who see is going to
be a work and we've already started it
it's going to start with a solo for me
first time I've been back on stage in
quite a few years now dancing so much as
moving in a spatially provocative way
this ship it's being commissioned by the
armory huge space like I think two
football fields or something and I did a
version of it at MASS MoCA I was invited
by Nick Cave a wonderful visual artist
and he had created kind of oceanic decor
and yes people artists to come in and
quote respond to it so mine was this
walking constantly and holding something
lasted free elastic free Almighty God
think will lasted free spiritual Negro
old and be will black boys white boys
black girls white girls Jews Gentiles
Catholics hold hands and in the words of
the old Negro spiritual say free at last
free at last thank God Almighty I'm free
at last
but I do it backwards and it sounds very
strange it sounds very much like
nonsense it sounds mad and the idea is
as on walking lips do you care enough
about it that you turn it around I don't
know how you all are feeling about we're
all going to grab hands and say free at
last
I'm not feeling it right now how are you
doing you feel like part of the great
family of humanity or do you feel like a
woman
know something about being oppressed and
raped and explored it do you feel like a
gay person do I need to go through the
litany of things we've just got the
right to declare Pro openly that we can
marry do you feel like a trans person
that is often invisible there are any
trans persons in the room right now I'm
sure you could talk you could say what
I've heard from people who work with me
and what job joined the company the
world is very blind to who they we are
do you feel like a Native American do
you feel like an immigrant where is the
great project of we-we-we that they
taught us about maybe it's just
temporary huh so deep Lucy has built e
Jones is well-known activist voice
walking and chanting one of the most
loved documents backwards and of every
once in a while this story of PIP keeps
bubbling up the second section of the
piece is my company my company how many
there's we're almost equal five and five
the numbers are are changing all the
time and I say that this is if the first
section is about loneliness the second
section is about what the company has
been it's been a kind of a boat of
Cocoon or something that has kept me
madness and all I think as time goes on
I become more mad more mercurial more
angry at a flash more loving more
risk-taking success is a Sun Oven
success is difficult
as free DeRozan my lesbian socialist
therapist used to say you know success
has a conservative effect on people when
you have something to lose it's not so
easy to apply right you got a bank
account you have a tenured position
somewhere you have children free at last
free at last free from what
so this first section lonely man second
section with the company third section
now 100 people hopefully 100 people that
looked like the world we'd like to live
in and when we did it at the Armory was
an amazing that way we did a work in
progress it had to be very fast because
try paying everybody to be there are a
hundred people there was the sense that
look one of the few times in my life I
was in a room where there were more
people of color than white people that's
the other part about the bill T Jones
narrative it's hard to have a black
audience why do you care what color the
audience is why do we care what color
the audience is what did you say about
call-and-response oh it's deep isn't it
you want to open your mouth and say how
you doing alright you want to feel the
funk come through the air you don't want
as my sister said I want to be people
who know my name what does she mean by
that
my mother's name her mother's name but
was the first time and this work which
will probably be it will be toured
around the states will probably we're
definitely going to Holland festival
Germany Manchester
I wonder how it'll play at Europe
because they think that we have to teach
problems here that are not their
problems and it's not true what would it
mean to get a hundred people in Germany
to come out and be the voices or the
bodies of the disenfranchised or the
invisible persons what does it mean to
get ten trans people to come and share
this time with people who maybe are
extremely I think that some of those
people there actually know any trans
people the people who came to support me
do they really know what it's like to
share a dressing room with a trans
person I don't but everywhere we go at
this piece that will be one of the
things that we do we have to find that
community the one that is now the boat
that is built each owns our design
company has moved into the waters of a
different world making in this era the
world that is so broken up so fractions
and so angry
I won't presume I'm gonna stop at a
moment maybe you'll tell me what are you
doing with anger what are you doing
sometimes it shakes me to my bone it
shakes me to my damn bones my friend
says to me my companion says you know
you know it was always black everything
is black now black and white what
happened I was at Woodstock when I was
17 remember I was naked swimming
turn on tune in drop out you are not
your body or not your parents you're
something else your spirit your light
did I lose something I don't know maybe
you'll tell me anger
happiness community.we sanity
you know hey I gave a version of this
speech at a thing called campfire and
this is mr. Jeff Bezos yes that Jeff
Bezos he once a year invites 200 people
Reese Witherspoon Tom Ford John Hamm of
Mad Men bill T Jones Marlon James and
Bette Midler we're just for weekend you
eat canapes and drink wine and everyone
quote I was just hanging out together
though they take the whole Biltmore
incidentally and it's all they flew us
out by chartered planes and all so
imagine being on stage with a room like
that and saying the people particularly
since Arnie died and I became a very
public about certain aspects of my
biography they would journalists
oftentimes in France would say well mr.
Jones you are an artiste on Gachet what
does that mean artiste on Bechet the
implication is that it's an engaged
artist you're engaged in the world where
as artists as understood before this era
of identity we're dealing with something
up here artists are dealing with cure
ideas Apollonian aspirations and then
our generation we're now producing the
likes of Bill T Jones that are engaged
some people say they're confused because
they should be doing politics but they
think they're making art I don't care so
here I am performing and I'm saying what
should an artist do and this is an old
saw the line you probably have heard it
I said an artist should be the freest
person in the society sometimes
literally running naked literally
running naked through the streets
thumbing their nose at all received
wisdom don't tell me
don't tell me an artist should be the
freest person but an artist is a man a
woman sis man cisgendered man sister
nude woman transgender person an artist
is a person with a location what class
were you born in an artist is a person
who is in some ways determined by what
your bank account what's your credit
card status an artist is a person and
what does that person need or want to do
so when someone says to you what should
an artist do you try giving them that be
free be truthful be free be truthful so
some of the adults in the room are
probably laughing so easy to say isn't
it
those are words that usually only young
people use the rest of us have gone from
black and white to a kind of grey and
that's where I am today
that's the truth of Who I am right now
the person that you heard about this
person is going from one day to the
other from one question to the other
from one project to the other and hoping
that something happens do I want you to
love me yeah I do and if you don't I
suffer it's so what does the work get
deeper its my construction better is the
understanding the intention of what I do
getting clearer and an old saw again the
great Marcel Duchamp you will know who
he is of course in some ways you
couldn't have a lot of modern art that
we do including Andy Warhol all those
people without this French
who had this idea about art that it is
primarily an intellectual activity that
comes in through the eyes goes through
the mind I say art comes in through the
eyes goes to the mind and if it's good
enough it goes to the heart but that's
not for everybody is that the black part
is that the African part I'm messing
with you
no answers just questions and gratitude
and gratitude walk walk
don't you get weary walk walk
don't you get weary what what don't you
get weary you help me finish it I know I
know I learned it from Jesse Norman
myself but this was supposedly a song
that was back I believe it's slavery
when you've been working from the dawn
to the end of the day the light is
failing you are tired but you can see
the bar you can see it you better walk
walk don't you get we're we're gonna do
the same thing tomorrow and the day
after that and we're in bondage but
right now we have to walk keep moving
keep moving keep moving keep moving that
is what I'm doing right now in my art
trying to put one step in front of the
other and look at you all will you
remember this you're not obliged to
someday they're gonna say there was this
dude called Jones oh yeah I think yeah
they my teacher took us to see him talk
once and he talked a lot you know you
know doesn't matter does it
what did my Angelo say her grandmother
told her I don't know what to make of
this Bjorn
well she said people think entirely too
much
about their position in the world she
said bring me a bucket of water over
here you know he's black women right
bring me a bucket water over here you
want to know what difference you make in
the world take your hand and put it in
that water now take it out look at the
water do you see any imprint on that
water that is a vision of life now how
do you put that together with the big
feelings that drive art-making with the
desire for truth and change how do you
put that put your hand in the water take
it out look at the surface of the water
there's no trace how do you put those
realities together
walk walk don't you get weary
let's stop thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you thank you
how much time do we have Maureen we got
a little time Maureen yes let's take a
few questions let's talk a little bit
yes sir what's your name Jordan how's
the sound Jordan yeah cuz he was here
earlier and we were doing the sound
shake and he spoke up thank you for that
Jordan what's on your mind well it
actually turns into Jesus Christ you
know and I don't really quite there's a
campground meeting on the promised land
walk walk don't you get really there's a
campground meeting in the promised land
I don't like I'm not interested in the
Promised Land what I get here there's my
problem with a lot of music of our
people they're always being promised
something it's gonna get better
I don't know maybe I'm just a crass
materialistic 21st century person but no
I want I want it here I want you and me
to share it why do you ask that
you feel the walk
and your young man and yeah good for you
remember this moment in 30 years you
said to me I feel the walk and I said
you're young and then you're gonna be I
don't know look looking at you you're
probably gonna be roughly my age maybe a
little younger and will you be weary
then when you still be able to walk I
don't know we don't know do we
life has surprises for us
anyone else yes thank you very much
bye-bye
and lord have mercy
come please just one moment please we
will continue just walk out like that
now it's one of my oldest friends good
to see you
good to see you angry yes sir what were
you saying well whatever they'd like
whatever they need to do that's
different you know whatever they like or
whatever they need to do yes please
continue yeah
[Music]
[Music]
utilitarian no I'm saying does that what
you mean art that has a use of social
use always set the response from society
hey yeah maybe that's good nowadays cuz
you know there was a time when people
used to say to me man you know if you
want to do politics - politics we make
art make art what in merce think about
it
yes it's influenced by yourself it's
coming out of yourself it's coming out
of you is your voice yours mm-hmm
anyways please please keep guard
[Music]
are you are you an artist but have you
made anything okay well let's just talk
like people who make right because you
know art does a lot of things it wants
us in the world and in a way you do give
it away once it's in the world unless
it's a body based art and your body is
the object of it that's a different
issue
so I'm trying to descend what you're
saying you would like to think that
there's still this separation there is
the political utilitarian art and then
there is this other one what's the other
one oh my goodness
the message got to your generation
didn't it I thought that was my best
line thirty years ago all art is
political because if you look at is so
let's say Jackson Pollock paint is that
political
how so also sorts about the intention of
the artist
[Music]
yes
so what's the intention what's your name
Julia hold are you yes you dance y-yes
oh do you think you're gonna live a long
time mm-hmm
we're walking we're walking backwards
now why are we doing this yeah because I
asked you to write yeah do you think I
had an intention when I asked you to
come up here and if I did is it him is
it political
lean on you open your legs a little
wider little wider than your knees more
how far can you go until it's too much
they let me know it is too much see now
in some circles this is a duet and you
saw it happen right in front of you I
don't know if it's a great duet but to
do it we just made something I made it
in the moment
so is it political yes I am also I'm
older she could bother be my
granddaughter right we're both African
she's female
I'm male there's all sorts of stuff you
can read into what we're about but what
does it mean what it means is what's
going on in your head right now you
determine what the meaning is and you my
brother I encourage you to get out of
the way of your own being make something
that you don't know why you don't know
how you don't know where it's gonna go
make it hopefully you don't hurt anybody
make it and then make another one then
things begin to happen people have
responses to it you have responses to
their response and before you know it
there's a conversation going on around
what you do that's the promise of
art-making I thank you for being so
articulate and brave enough to speak up
in this moment that's very powerful it's
a good thing an artist has happened but
some artists never speak they hate to
speak they just do this is a brave woman
she came here to be an audience she's
now a performer or is she a performer
[Music]
one more yes sir
hmm I've been playing with it for years
I've been playing it with it for years
and because I always wanted to feel like
the best preaching oh that's a Southern
Baptist Black Southern Baptist feeling
right I wanted to feel like it's coming
out I am calling out and then your
applause your attention is another way
of coming forward it Shores me up and I
want to give you something so whatever
it takes to do it if it's a beautiful
prose if it's Shakespeare Martin Luther
King
he's a very good writer but what is he
saying
it has utility it has purpose but it's
also he is when he says so you can hear
it in his voice free at last free at
last you know that's pretty authentic
he's sharing something very precious
with you then that is then that as my
high school teacher Mary shape he said
she was trying it out on me when the
speech was happening she said it's an
example of bathos I said what you know
that's that's sort of the the logic
isn't it of speeching it's like putting
together an argument and it's is it an
intellectual pursuit or is it an
emotional pursuit with the
african-american prophetic tradition
they come together you that's why so
many of the political leaders in
african-american life had been actually
religious leaders I'm not so done with
religion but I understand why that works
that way so in a way if you are are you
an artist mm-hmm are you a sincere
person yeah do you understand irony how
in sincerity can be used but used for a
purpose that is sincere correct because
anything other than that if
Jews for a purpose it's more lies on top
of lies and cleverness for the sake of
cleverness it will be found out and it
will be nothing in much pop culture is
that its purpose is to entertain you
it's like eating McDonald's french fries
not very good for you but it's tastes
really good but then the next day it's
gone yeah so sincerity you smart people
right too smart and two men spoke let's
hear it for this department you got here
because oftentimes the men are quiet but
sincerity and it's opposite you know
what I say when people come to watch my
work and people wonder how do I do this
I say watch yourself watching where did
you you yawned earlier right you know
so should I lost her oh no okay well
maybe she needs a nap right get up so
where is there that moment when you are
as my mother says you step out on the
word she's a religious woman does that
happen for artists doesn't happen in
academia when someone is transported
there's some impulse that is without
shaped without name poets do this all
the time they're putting a couple of
words together to suggest something that
is beyond description they have to
believe in those words yeah thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]